Hi there, Steve Kaufman here, and today
I wanna talk about getting started
and some of the common proverbs or
expressions there are around getting
started and how I think we should
get started in learning a language.
There is an expression that Aristotle
quotes or quoted, uh, referring to a
proverb that already existed in ancient
Greece, some 300 odd years uh, BCE and
that is well begun is the job half done.
So it's important to begin the job
well, and then you'll do the job well.
There's another expression that comes
from about the same period or a little
earlier attributed to Laozi in, in,
uh, Chinese classics, which says the
thousand li, mile call it the thousand
mile march begins with the first step.
So two different proverb talking about
the importance of getting started.
Uh, I thought about this because
last little while I've kind of not
been doing much language learning,
haven't done much with my Farsi, uh,
so I don't listen to content, then
I don't speak to my Iranian tutor.
And uh, that kind of was the
situation for quite a few days.
And then I had to clean up the kitchen.
There was quite a big mess there.
So I'll put on my Iranian history
series and the thing is, once you
get started again, all of a sudden
everything comes back to life.
So now I'm interested again in
learning Persian, and then I say,
yeah, I'm gonna book another session
with Sahra online, with my tutor.
So sometimes, you know, you can
hang back and the same is true of
exercising, hang back and not do
something for something for a while.
Convince yourself you don't
wanna do it or whatever.
Once you get started
you're back into it again.
So it's very important
to take that first step.
As Laozi said, the first step on that
thousand mile thousand li march gets
you going, and once you get going,
chances are you'll stay with it.
Hopefully get some good habits.
Also, getting back to Aristotle's,
uh, the proverb that he quoted well
begun is the job have done, and his
inference was that if you start something
properly, you're likely to complete it.
So assuming we want to get into language
learning or we wanna get back to the
language who we were learning, so then
what is properly, what is well done?
Well, in terms of a new language,
I'm convinced that our mini
stories at LingQ, you won't be
surprised to hear me say that, to
me that's the place to get started.
You shouldn't get started on lists of
colors or lists, you know, um, members
of the family or any, or people, uh,
you know, at the train station or any
of the traditional stuff that's put
in language, uh, books, you shouldn't
try upfront to understand the grammar.
You can maybe have an overview,
which is easy enough to do.
I mean, you can just Google or go to
chat GPT and ask for, you know, a summary
of the basics of Punjabi grammar and
you'll get it, but you won't remember it.
But it's kind of a bit of an
overview, which is fine to have.
Which is fine to have, but really
to get started, well begun, you
have to get into the language.
You have to get into content
which has a lot of repetition and
hopefully high frequency verbs.
As I've said before, the reason
I think our mini stories are so
superior to most beginner content
is that there's so much repetition.
Uh, the same high frequency verbs
repeat within each story, and
they continue showing up in other
stories over the full 60 stories.
Whereas typically in a beginner
book, you're moving from the train
station to going through customs to
visiting the doctor, uh, post office,
and the vocabulary doesn't repeat.
It doesn't repeat within each
story or within each lesson.
It doesn't repeat across the lessons.
And we need so much repetition initially
to get a sense of the language that I
think that that is the place to start.
Not super boring stu...
hello, my name is...
not necessary.
It'll show up.
Uh, there's no need to, you know, at
the very beginning, how old are you?
It'll come up.
And how often in conversation or
in listening to the language do you
actually need to say how old you are?
Un unless you are deliberately
creating a conversation for the
sake of having a conversation,
then that's likely to come up.
But in reality, it doesn't
come up that often.
And if it does come up, if you have a
good base in the language, you'll quickly
learn how to say, how old are you?
Or, you know, whatever, however
many years old, it's far better
to sort of jump in midstream.
Midstream, albeit shallow water,
like the mini stories with a lot
of repetition, but it is midstream.
It's into the language.
You're starting to absorb the language.
You're listening to the language.
You're reading the language.
You're looking up words, you're listening.
Again, that's how you get into
learning a language and if you
stay with it for a few months, you
actually get a sense of the language.
And with that sense of the language
language, you can now start to make sense
of some of the grammatical explanations.
Uh, don't try to, you know, study
conjugation tables, declension tables,
remember rules, all of that is gonna
set you back, discourage you, make you
think the language is very difficult.
Just get into the language.
You know, I can mix my metaphors
here, you know, jump right in,
but then I said shallow water.
So you don't wanna jump into shallow
water, but get going into sort of
the mainstream of the language,
albeit with relatively simple, high
frequency vocabulary, and you'll get
a head start on learning the language.
The language will be well begun,
and therefore, eventually will
be hopefully a job well done.
So just thought I would share with you
that sense of the importance of getting
started and getting started the right way.
Thanks for listening.
Bye for now.